[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission où ça découvre la
Réunion ensemble vous allez parler alors
allons-nous
[Musique]
sur le parking de la forêt
Sainte-Marguerite
et Nana un grand portail alors soit
l'occasion pour nous de faire un
aller-retour pour nous découvre la forêt
Sainte-Marguerite
mais bon maintenant
bonjour monsieur bonjour Comment allez
bien
[Musique]
que ça aussi bien elle est bien
entretenu et tout le chantier il passe
sur Gouillard
alors mes amis ça rentre en sous-bois un
monsieur
bonjour ça va ou même on est bien oui ça
va dis-moi
pour faire simple c'est savoir quand
est-ce qu'un pied de bois les fleurs et
quand est-ce qu'il va donner des fruits
pour pouvoir par la suite comment
récolter ses fruits là ces graines pour
mettre dans la pépinière
pépinière
qui plante et nous on a des équipes
aussi qui entretient par adolescentiers
le ns de Sainte-Marguerite c'est une
forêt de 150 hectares d'accord on a
juste une dizaine d'hectares au vélo
public et concernant de de particulier
qu'on va retrouver ce site là alors
c'est un site les très très riche en
espèces endémique indigènes
très très riche nous estime tout confond
Audi au moins 200 espèces de variétés de
plantes en passant par les autres qui
défougères pieds de bois tout ça et nous
les là justement pour conserver
conserver les différents milieux que
Nana est-ce que d'autres actions les
avenir sur le site alors nous
n'agrandissement de la pépinière
justement dans le cadre des projets un
million de pieds de bois que le
département est met en place nous les
actuellement à plus de 2000 pieds de
bois par an que nous plante sur la forêt
de Marguerite en espèces indigène et
endémique
au moins 3000
[Musique]
la montagne
mais la réunion nous les larmes mon pays
comment il est la réunion ça m'a mis et
ben voilà après on va dire une bonne
heure de montée par contre faut pas
venir qu'on en a la pluie parce que sur
le sentier la dernière partie était
vraiment boueuse et noir arrive ici à la
limite du sentier alors de l'autre côté
là-bas tu vas retrouver la peine
d'épargne en tout cas nous continuons
sur notre tour et nous va aller voir la
pépinière allez nous ça va
aller bonjour monsieur bonjour comment
allez-vous
ça va merci
de faire développer les différentes
espèces de cette forêt là justement pour
restaurer la partie basse qu'elle a été
dégradé auparavant d'accord voilà et
donc en fait de la pépinière
la zone de germination et la zone
d'adaptation tout ça il est un peu
bonnes espèces ou plantes alors ben ici
le NASA ma ville
en rouge mena le STO café tout ça et
donc ça c'est dans le but de du plan 1
million d'arbres que le département l'a
mis en place et donc c'est vraiment pour
restaurer toutes les parties que la télé
et là c'est ouvert par mois c'est
vraiment bonnes espèces endémiques ici
ça endémique indigènes que nous on va
retrouver sur sur ce site là d'accord et
aujourd'hui à où travaille sur le site
et c'est coûte plus grande fierté ah ben
déjà là depuis 22 ans donc la fiate est
déjà c'est l'évolution de la forêt qu'on
nous voit nos regards par exemple laver
une zone que l'été dévastée elle avait
pas rien mais aujourd'hui regardez les
arbres qui arrivent trois quatre mètres
de haut donc ça c'est déjà une fierté et
puis de valoriser tout ça et surtout de
sensibiliser les jeunes parce que demain
il faut que les jeunes ils continuent ça
d'accord il faut que demain nous
retrouvons ça que les jeunes y a
propriété ça ça allait et donc il faut
protéger
vous allez
bien alors dites moi vous allez où comme
ça
petit
d'accord vous venez souvent dans la
forêt de Marguerite c'est la deuxième
fois qu'on vient du code de ce côté
d'accord vous habitez
souvent de la randonnée c'est important
pour vous deux jours pratiquement tous
les jours et pourquoi ça parce que
Madame elle est folle de marcher
[Rires]
et puis ça fait du bien et puis la
Réunion c'est beau à visiter bon en tout
cas
bonne journée au revoir merci
dans la forêt Sainte-Marguerite tu es
vraiment Gaïa elle est vraiment riche je
suis au tout un espace économique ok la
réunion les Gaia à long pour le temps
Vitali et pour ça on nous a un prochain
épisode de mission de nous cette fois-ci
sera dans la communauté rose et on va
découvrir le sentier de la semaine la
trouve
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]